mr. scramble do you know anything about
the Wizarding community in America
what's kind of intriguing for me about
the film is that Newt and his suitcase
it's a kind of entrance into a much
bigger story the scale of that and I max
screen is like something to behold where
else have you got in there you're going
into this extraordinary world new york
city of 1926 intima clues are the
magical congress of the united states of
america these wondrous fantastic world
and what better place to see it on the
scale with the clarity and with the
authenticity that imax offers you you
don't know I'm just like look at it on a
tiny little screen you want to be
immersed in it but also just to share it
with other people there's nothing better
than sure it's sharing a story with 500
people you don't know on an enormous
screen and sharing what the human
experience is all about you laugh at the
same time you're thrilled at the same
time you jump at the same time you're
moved at the same time I'm actually
you're gonna feel like you're there you
would be doing yourself with the service
not to see it on that massive scale
fantastic beasts who is open just a
smidge experience it in imax